♪ ♪
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU KNOW WHEN
SOMETHING GOOD HAS HAPPENED?
THE LEFT IMPLODES.
TAKE THE TAX BILL WHICH HAS
TWISTED DEMOCRATS INTO BITTER
PRETZELS.
WE SAY THE BILL BENEFITS THE
RICH, THEY CALL THE REBATES
CRUMPLE ME LOOK STUPID.
IT'S LIKE NOTING THAT A CHEF IS
FAT WHILE HE IS COOKING FREE
MEALS AT A SHELTER.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO REPEAL IT.
I HOPE THEY TRY.
IN A RECENT TOWN HALL,
NANCY PELOSI CLAIMS THE BILL WAS
PASSED IN THE DEAD OF NIGHT, A
MASSIVE LIE, EVEN FOR HER.
SHE KNEW MORE ABOUT THE TAX BILL
THAN WE KNEW ABOUT HER IMMENSE
WEALTH.
ON "THE FIVE," WE DEBATED IT FOR
MONTHS.
NONE OF US LOVED IT COMPLETELY
BECAUSE WE KNEW WHAT WAS IN IT.
UNLIKE OBAMACARE, A FLAMING MASK
DUMPED ON AMERICA'S PORCH, AT
MIDNIGHT, THERE'S THIS.
>> IF WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
CUTTING TAXES AT THE HIGH END
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO INVEST
WITH THE FUTURE, YOU'RE DOING A
GRAVE DISSERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY.
>> Greg: YEAH.
THE BILL IS UNPATRIOTIC.
HOW SO?
THE MILLIONS OF BONUSES FROM
CORPORATIONS?
IF IT'S NOT FROM NANCY, THEN
IT'S TREASON.
OR WAGE INCREASES THAT CAME AS A
DIRECT RESULT OF THE CUTS.
IS THAT UNPATRIOTIC ART?
IF IT'S NOT WELFARE CLIP MUST BE
EVIL.
THE FACT IS PELOSI, WHAT'S
UNPATRIOTIC IS ANY SOLUTION THAT
HER PARTY DIDN'T COME UP WITH.
WHETHER IT'S IMMIGRATION REFORM
OR TAX CUTS, IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT
UNLESS IT'S DONE BY THE LEFT.
AND THEN BOY, DOES IT SUCK.
WE HAVE TO PLAY THIS, WHICH I
JUST SAW.
NANCY PELOSI OFFERING DEMOCRATIC
SUGGESTIONS FOR BORDER SECURITY.
IT INVOLVES A LAWN MOWER.
>> LET'S SIT DOWN AND TALK THIS
THROUGH AND SEE WHAT MAKES
SENSE.
NOT SOME COMMITMENT TO A PROMISE
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BUILD A
WALL IN MEXICO IS GOING TO PAY
FOR IT.
THAT'S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT WHERE A
MORE SERIOUS STRUCTURE MIGHT BE
NECESSARY WERE FENCING WOULD DO
OUR MOWING THE GRASS SO PEOPLE
CAN'T GET SMUGGLED THROUGH THE
GRASS.
THAT IS SOMETHING.
TECHNOLOGY, PERSONNEL.
>> Greg: I THINK THIS IS THE
RALLYING CRY FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
MOLD THE LAWN.
>> Jesse: MOW THE LAWN, THE
CRUMBS.
A WHOLE HOST OF UNFORCED ERRORS
FROM NANCY.
THE LAWSUIT TAX DEBATE IN THEIR
MESSAGING HAS BEEN ATROCIOUS.
THEY POSITION THEMSELVES AS
BEING AGAINST PEOPLE KEEPING
MORE OF THEIR MONEY.
YOU SEE IT IN THE POLLS.
HAVING DEMOCRATS SUPPORT FOR THE
TAX CUTS DOUBLED FROM 9% TO 18%.
THE REST OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC,
IT'S OVER 50%.
JUAN SAID SOMETHING THE OTHER
DAY THAT I FOUND INTERESTING
ABOUT THE POPULARITY OF THE TAX
BILL.
HE SAID HE IS SURPRISED THE TAX
CUTS WARRANTED 90% POPULARITY.
I'M GLAD TO HEAR YOU SAY THAT,
JUAN, THAT YOU ADMIT 90% OF THE
COUNTRY WANTS TO KEEP MORE OF
THEIR MONEY.
MAYBE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY CAN
LISTEN TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND START CUTTING TAXES.
>> Greg: JUAN, RESPOND.
>> Juan: IF WE HAVE A POOL ON
ICE CREAM, APPLE PIE, AND
GRANDMOTHERS, WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE RESULT SHOULD BE?
IF IT WAS 50%, YOU WOULD SAY
WHAT THE HELL.
HOW CAN 50% OF AMERICA NOT LIKE
GRANDMA'S APPLE DUMPLINGS.
WE HAVE A TAX CUT MR. TRUMP SAYS
IS THE GREATEST THING EVER, AND
IT'S ONLY NOW APPROACHING 50%.
ACCORDING TO THE POLLS, IT'S
ONLY A QUARTER OF AMERICANS WHO
SAY THEY HAVE SEEN ANYTHING, ANY
KIND OF BUMP IN THEIR PAY.
I SEE.
>> Jesse: 80%.
>> Juan: 25%.
>> Jesse: IT'S WRONG.
>> Juan: IS NOT WRONG.
USING ABOUT THE REALITY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS SOMETHING
AND YOU PLAY NANCY PELOSI
BECAUSE YOU LOVE TO BEAT UP
NANCY PELOSI.
>> Dana: THEY ARE HER WORDS.
>> Juan: NANCY PELOSI SAYS
SOMETHING THAT MAKES TOTAL SENSE
WHICH IS THE MEXICANS AREN'T
PAYING FOR THIS WALL.
HE PROMISED DURING THE CAMPAIGN
THE MEXICANS.
NOW WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY
FOR IT AND HE IS SAYING YOU KNOW
WHAT?
WE HAVE WAYS TO FORCE YOU TO PAY
FOR IT.
WHY DON'T REPUBLICANS SAY THAT'S
JUST CRAZY?
>> Greg: DANA.
>> Dana: SOMETHING
CHRIS STIREWALT SAID A FEW WEEKS
AGO ON THE DAILY BRIEFING SURE
THE PODCAST FOR THE BEST THING
NANCY PELOSI COULD DO FOR THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MIDTERMS IS
WAIT UNTIL THE FOURTH OF JULY
RECESS AND RETIRE.
OR NOW SHE'S NOT GOING TO RUN
AGAIN AS SPEAKER.
LET THE NEW GENERATION PUSH IT
FORWARD.
>> Kimberly: I THINK IT'S VERY
OBVIOUS AT THIS POINT THAT THE
TIME HAS COME.
WHAT DO REPUBLICANS NEED TO SAY?
JUST LET NANCY PELOSI KEEP ON
TALKING TO BE QUITE HONEST.
SHE'S NOT MAKING ANY SENSE.
SHE SAYS THINGS IN A COMPLETELY
NONSENSICAL.
AT LEAST REPUBLICANS ARE PUTTING
FORWARD LEGISLATION.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO KEEP MORE OF
THEIR MONEY.
SHE IS FIGHTING KIND OF A LOSING
CAUSE AND DOESN'T HAVE ANY
SUPPORT OR ANY GOOD METAPHORS,
ANALOGIES, OR EXAMPLES.
>> Greg: OR IT COULD BE SHE IS
ON GRASS.
NO ONE USES THAT WORD ANYMORE.
THAT IS LIKE FROM DRAGNET.
>> Jesse: JUAN USES IT.
>> Juan: I ASKED JESSE, HEY,